yeah let's go ahead awesome um
hi everybody i'm emma runskill i'm an
assistant professor of computer science
at stanford university and i'll be doing
the batch offline rl tutorial
um and that will be um both for this
hour and for the next hour
so i think um i think it's often helpful
to know where people are coming from
in terms of the presenters that you're
gonna hear from um and
i've been you know i think one of the
reasons why we're so excited to have the
reinforcement learning
session right now is just the
extraordinary um benefits that we've
been seeing
let me just see if i can make that oh no
that didn't work one second
put that back okay
something strange okay i'm not sure why
there's that extra thing at the top but
that's okay
um there's just been some really
extraordinary successes of using
reinforcement learning um
over the last five to ten years in atari
and the amazing results for go etc
but i'm a professor like many other
people here or many people here are
involved in academia
and i think when people ask me if
reinforcement learning is solved or if
we're done
i think about a challenge that many of
us have to face every quarter
um which is office hours you've assigned
a new homework assignment and then
for the first office hours you're going
to have a series of students coming in
and it's really this partially
observable markov decision process
problem where you're trying to quickly
figure out how to help each student
reach some understanding and you want to
quickly figure out strategies that help
not just this student but future
students
you often have costs and budget
constraints and
we don't have any sort of reinforcement
learning system that can handle this
type of complexity
and so in my own work the reason why i'm
personally so excited about
reinforcement learning is i think it not
only
that for any quest for sort of general
artificial intelligence we have to think
about you know to quickly learn to make
good robust decisions
but also because i think that if we can
make progress on this it's so
core to being able to advancing the use
of artificial intelligence for human
benefit
in things like education and health care
and many other people facing
applications
and the really exciting thing to me as a
researcher is that as we try to tackle
those applications
it also introduces all these really
beautiful theoretical questions that we
don't know the answers to
and so i think really in my own lab it
can be summarized by sort of a
deceptively simple question which is
most the time we think about how do we
learn from limited samples to robustly
make good decisions
and when we try to formalize how to do
this this naturally
invokes a huge number of theoretical
challenges
now um of course you've seen this sort
of slide many times now
in terms of reinforcement learning i
just want to be clear about some
notation
i'll be using actions to devote a to
devote x
to the note actions s which will
frequently be
a continuous vector but not always and
i'll try to be clear if i'm ever
thinking about the tabular setting
but most of the time today i'll be
thinking about actions being discrete
so this will normally be discrete so
normally
discrete for most of the time the
problems that i'm thinking about today
s will normally be sort of continuous
often vectored
and then we have some reward signal and
as usual we're gonna so even though i've
written
um a sum there over s prime generally
we're going to be thinking about
s prime as being an integral over next
states we might reach
um and as usual we don't know the
dynamics or the reward model
now i've written down here sort of the
standard markov decision process
approach but we'll also get into that
further about whether we're considering
that or other settings
and what the focus of this tutorial is
is on
there there's sort of a many different
terms for it but
counterfactual or batch rl this is also
often called offline rl
i'm going to try not to use off policy
too much because that can often refer to
online
as well but really the setting we're
considering here is that we have some
data set
of past data and i'm going to think
about those as being trajectories
so sequences of state action reward next
states
and that we're going to assume for now
that those are all generated by
a particular behavior policy we'll get
into later whether or not we know what
pi b
is or not um and we can often extend
these ideas to when there's multiple pi
b's
but essentially the idea is that we're
not going to be tackling exploration at
all
um in this tutorial the idea is that all
the data has been previously collected
and whatever we're going to do with
respect to
that data that that's all that we have
access to
and so the outline for the tutorial
today is to first talk about sort of
the general setting the tasks the
assumptions the
type of objectives that we might want to
solve when we think about offline or
batch reinforcement learning
and why i think it's one of the most
exciting problems um right now in the
field
um and then talk about two the two of
the most common
tasks offline batch evaluation and
offline batch learning and optimization
and then highlight some of the recent
additional directions
either in terms of relaxing assumptions
or new types of objectives that i think
are particularly promising
so um the the question really that batch
reinforcement learning tries to get at
um is this what if reasoning given past
data
so consider the following scenario where
we have um electronic medical record
systems
where for each individual we see a
series of
treatments or interactions with that
individual so maybe
we um prescribe some medicine and then
they had a doctor's appointment
and we saw some outcome about their
health
with which was had a score of 92. and
then maybe for
a second individual they were prescribed
two different types of medications over
time
and eventually their outcome was 91.
and the idea is that we'd have a whole
sequence of these and and the key
question really is what do we do for a
new individual
um and this is a really challenging
problem for many different reasons
and it's fundamentally different than
supervised learning
for those of you who are sort of come
from that background
and the first question the challenge is
that data is censored
so we just can't know what would it
would have happened for a particular
individual
um in this case the top individual if
for this woman we had
um say given them a different sequence
of uh
treatments or um actions essentially
and so we can only live one life we
don't know you don't know right now how
much better your life would be if you
were drinking coffee outside
and you get to experience this
particular trajectory and so data is
fundamentally censored
so that's one reason why this is really
a hard problem and this is a problem
that comes up in
single time step decisions too in the
bandit setting
the other thing that i think is
particularly important when we think
about
reinforcement learning and we're making
not one decision for an individual but
the sequence of decisions
um is the need for generalization so if
we think about here here i've shown you
just a bit of a two-time step
decision process um the the number of
different actions we could see here
generally um you know grows
combinatorially with the horizon
of course we can use state and other
things to try to reduce that
but in general there's just going to be
an enormous number of different
strategies
and orderings of different actions and
interventions and we're just not it's
not going to be feasible to use the
standard scientific process
of a randomized control trial to
consider every different possible
sequence
and so it would be really nice if we can
to do some form of generalization
so that we confer can infer that even
though maybe we've never tried
starting with a checkup and then
prescribing a medication
for this particular um condition that
based on the previous data we've seen um
under certain assumptions we may be able
to interpolate or extrapolate
to predict how good this sort of never
before experienced future
will be i think it's a pretty amazing
time
for for thinking about these types of
problems um
generally i think in the field of
artificial intelligence and machine
learning
they're just growing interest in this
area of causal inference and machine
learning
um not just for decision making but even
for building predictive models that we
think will generalize better
in terms of being able to capture some
underlying structure
about the world but um there's also
but i think it's also important to note
that sort of historically even though
this this type of area has a long
history um there's there's a lot of
prior work and things like statistics
and biostatistics
um and economics that a lot of this work
has really focused on this question of a
single binary decision
so we might want to do something like
treatment effect estimation where we
think about what would be the expected
treatment effect
um maybe conditioned on a particular
individual
compared to a control and so there's an
enormous body of research
on this going back decades um but really
that's
from a rl perspective that's considering
the bandit problem with two actions
um and i think when we think about sort
of the rl perspective there's
an enormous number of problems where
we're not just making one decision
but we're making many many decisions
and the problem with that is that we
have to really deal with this challenge
of covariate shift
so what do i mean by covariate shift um
uh so um
i got a quick question which is you know
what does make uh causal imprints closer
to
batch offline rl than say supervised
learning i'll actually defer that i'm
not an expert in causal inference
that field itself is is super vast um i
think
what i'm trying to highlight here is
that for the aspects of causal
encounter factual reasoning where people
are thinking about this to try to make
decisions in the future um i think that
that community
there's a lot of strong relationships
between that and what people are
thinking about in the reinforcement
learning community
and there was a nice set of um there's a
nice workshop i think it was in icml
2018
where they tried to get people together
who come for more of like the judeo
pearl
tradition um with reinforcement learning
experts
thanks for the question so the challenge
when we think about doing this for
reinforcement learning we're making not
just a single decision but many
decisions is covariate shift
so fundamentally if we want to think
about how it might be to make a
different sequence of decisions or have
a different decision policy
by definition for this decision policy
to be different
than our behavior policy that we use to
make decisions in the past
that means for at least some states we
have to take different actions
and in general those different actions
will lead to different state
distributions
often by intention we would like that to
happen because we um
want to say have more patients have good
outcomes
so i really like this figure and by my
colleagues finale joshi velez and david
sonteg and a number of their wonderful
students
um where what they thought about to sort
of illustrate this problem is imagine
you have a bunch of electronic medical
record systems
uh medical record data and you look at
these patients
and you say well it might this is just
historical data you could think of each
of those dots as being a patient and
what you want to know is whether or not
if you have a decision policy that
applies mechanical ventilation
you know how will they do so you follow
that first line down
and then you say okay well so now under
my policy if these people experience
discomfort i'm going to apply sedation
and what you can see in each stage here
is that the number of patients
who happen to have received the decision
policy that you're prescribing
is going down and down and in some ways
you know depending on your behavior
policy this will happen very naturally
and so what this means is that over time
sort of you can end up with a very small
number of individuals
that got the particular treatment policy
that you want to evaluate
and that can cause lots of challenges in
terms of variance
and there's lots of different ways to
handle that that we'll try to get into
some of today
i also want to highlight that from a
theoretical perspe perspective
the challenge of sort of this covariate
shift and the difference between the
data that you have
in your database essentially from the
behavior policy
and the data that you expect to see in
the future has been noted even for
imitation learning um and there's
uh nice sort of prior theoretical
results including by ross and bagnell
and peter abel's group and others have
thought about this as well
to show how badly these errors
say in prediction or other aspects
can compound over time due to these
covariate shifts
now i'm going to talk today about the
setting where you have a fixed amount of
prior data
but i want to highlight that this
question of taking existing data
and using it to evaluate alternative
policies or
trying to extract better policies has an
enormous history um
and this idea of policy reinforcement
learning really goes you know all the
way back to q
learning so it has a history of at least
30 years and this has been really
extensively studied
over time and and there's been lots of
known challenges uh
to doing this from the reinforcement
learning community including sort of the
the deadly triad
of function approximation and off policy
learning
and doing this kind of dynamic
programming but what i want to highlight
is sort of how people have tried to
tackle this
has focused on particular different
types of objective functions
particularly when
we are doing this not for the um uh the
batch setting but in the case where we
get continuing data
so i think there's this really nice
figure from rich sutton and andy bartow
in
their recent updated textbook where what
they do is they sort of say well
imagine that we have like some subspace
of what value functions
um that are representable uh by some set
of parameters
um and what we could think about in this
case is that whenever you do a bellman
backup
you may kind of be projected out of that
space so
um it may be that the resulting value
function cannot be represented in your
original space
and so we can think about sort of how do
we constrain this or what type of error
might occur
in a lot of different ways and one of
the column
common ones to think about is projected
bellman error and so that looks at
if you then project back down into your
space so
your backed up value function can no
longer be represented in your original
space and now you're going to project it
back down
then what is the distance because we
know that under the
the bellman equation that if you're the
optimal policy
um then you're at a fixed point and so
one of the common objectives in this
case is to look at the projected bellman
error
and there's been a lot of you know
interesting work on that um
uh let me just pause for a second so
there's a question that said um by
covariation problem are we meaning that
the number of samples of the policy we
want to evaluate is small
um great question i think what we mean
generally is the covariate shift problem
is that
the distributions of states and actions
that we have in our data set under one
behavior policy
is not the same distribution of states
and actions as what we expect to see
under either say an optimal policy or
the policy we're evaluating um
and that's the covariate shift problem
so in comparison to supervised learning
where we normally assume that the
the data distribution is iid and will be
the same in our in our training set in
our test set
that that is no longer the case in
bacterial
so this is the common objective or this
is one of the common objectives
and i think in many problems including
some of the places we've had really
wonderful successes
um in things like robotics and video
games etc
a lot of these types of objectives have
worked really well
but i think one of the really very
exciting things to me is
well what if we aren't in the case where
we can continue to get data easily
so we're really in this batch you know
offline setting data is fixed
um and then how you know is this the
right objective we want to think about
so i put up here two particular examples
when i think healthcare
is a case where often it's hard to do
exploration and it's hard to do online
rl
and another is a a tutoring system
that's made by war child which is a
non-profit that helps kids in
conflict regions and we've been
collaborating with them looking at
trying to introduce some amount of
personalization and some of their
educational software
and for them um for example in uganda
they can deploy the software
on these tablets and then they'll get
them back a month later you just
you don't have real-time data collection
you don't have real-time
ability to change the policy online so i
think there's many cases where
it's just not reasonable to assume that
we're going to be able to get online
data all the time
but it really matters these are high
stakes cases um you know this is kids
learning this is um
people's treatments and um we would like
to see if we can do better
than right now but we would really like
to do that in a way where we have some
sort of assurances
about the policies we do and so i think
for there it's great to think about this
other objective which has been less
studied historically i think in in the
reinforcement learning community
but i think is really critical to think
about when we want to start moving to
these other settings
which is value error and again this is
still in sutton embardo's textbook
and what this says is let's think about
doing say a series of bellman backups
um maybe you're not in the space
ultimately
you have some value of the policy you
care about
and then you have maybe some error
between that and what you're estimating
and we would like that to be small and i
think that
um i've been really interested in that
sort of objective of saying like you
know how what is the error
in the prediction between how good we
think a decision policy will be
based on this uh historical data versus
its actual performance
and i think um for those of you that had
the chance to see anka dragon's
wonderful talk yesterday
i think this really is um a great chance
to think about
um a tutorial is a great chance to think
about you know what are the problems
we're trying to solve
and which of those do we each pick as
the ones we think are most important
and i think in particular the there's
been a huge amount of recent work um
in off policy rl and there's growing
work in batch rl which is super exciting
and a lot of these different approaches
come from sort of very different
motivations in terms of
the type of assumptions they make and
the type of evaluation criteria they're
trying to achieve
um their definitions of success and so i
think um
i'll of course be able to share my own
views about some of the ones i find
particularly exciting in terms of
um evaluation criteria but i think it's
really helpful to think about kind of
this cube of different um
spots that we can get into to compare
different types of approaches
so in particular what type of tasks are
common well i think
there are two common types of tasks one
is off
policy or offline
evaluation so this
is a single policy so um
for example it might be that there's
some uh you have some historical data
and you think that there might be a new
way to
treat blood pressure and you'd like to
see based on the historical data maybe a
different sequence of how to treat blood
pressure or different dosage scheme
which has been tried a little bit in the
past but maybe not completely can we
estimate from the historical data how
good that is
and i'll try sometimes i'll drop it for
um
sort of convenience but um and
reducing notation overload but i'll try
to often put in d
here to indicate that this estimate that
we have of the value of a policy
is really a function of the input data
so this is one very very common task
that we would like to be able to do and
then the other is um optimization
we're learning
which is often we don't care about just
you know knowing how good a particular
policy is what we really want to do
is to be able to find a good policy to
deploy in the future
um and we may want to also know what the
value is of that particular policy
so those are i would argue the two most
common tasks and that's where the
majority of the literature has been
focused
but i'll try to highlight it again at
the end a couple different tasks
um that are common and i will say too
you know in two hours i can't possibly
unfortunately do justice to the full um
amount of work that's been in this space
so i'll just try to kind of give a
highlight of different ways that i think
that we can kind of categorize these
types of approaches and give us senses
of some of the exciting open areas to
make progress on in the future
so emma there's a question on discord
about sort of independence assumptions
like
what are we going to assume i guess
within a trajectory obviously have
dependence because
there's a policy uh but if you could
just comment on
the independence assumptions yeah that's
a great question and it'll be
it depends on on the work some people
assume that there
is um a stationary distribution over
states and actions that is induced by a
behavior policy and that we get to
sample randomly from that
um other people assume that the data
might have been generated from for
example
a reinforcement learning system or
something like that where then your
behavior policy is not constant it's
changing over time
most of the work i think assumes that
you have a fixed behavior policy
and then you generate trajectories from
that policy where each time
you get to sample from an initial
starting state distribution
which may or may not be known and then
you generate um policies from that
so the second thing that i think is
incredibly important and
i'll try to go into a bit more later is
what are we assuming
what are we assuming for for our
algorithms and particularly for our
theory um
uh but it's it's really important for
our algorithms as well
and i i'm highlighting here some of the
the common assumptions that we make
and one that is often not even stated
but i think there's been some really
cool recent work
from um chelsea finn's group and also
phil thomas's
um they're just trying to relax some of
this at least in the online case
which is most the time we're assuming
that we're sort of fundamentally in a
stationary process
so that there's some markup decision
process or palm dp in the world there's
some decision process
sarcastic decision process and it's
fixed
and then we have some prior data from
acting that decision pilot
process probably for with a behavior
policy and that generated some data
and then we're going to compute um a new
policy to maybe deploy in the future
um and the fundamental assumption is
that we're acting in the same decision
process as before
so the world hasn't changed there's no
pandemic and
you could relax some of these and try to
think about sort of separate sources of
distribution shift
due to the fact that your decision
process itself has changed
but as a default almost all of the work
assumes that the
fundamentally you're in some decision
process and that is going to be the same
for the date you've collected and the
future the second is the mark off
assumption
um this is certainly not always made and
i'll try to highlight this later
it's a common assumption to make and it
can give us a lot of benefit when it's
true
in terms of statistical efficiency and
certainly empirical performance
but this is one where i would say you
know i mean half is a gross
generalization but a certain you know
a lot of people make this a lot of
papers make this assumption a lot of
papers specifically do not
a third assumption um which again is
i think even more common than markov
substantially more
which is almost all of the prior
literature that would come from sort of
an rl lens
would assume sequential ignorability um
or
it might be called the no confounding
assumption and the key assumption there
is that you have access to all the
variables and all the state information
that was used to make the decisions
um and i've put this here and this is
potential outcome notation
which i'm not going to go into much
today that comes more from like the
statistics and
econometrics communities um but the the
key idea here is that um
there is not an additional hidden
confounder um
which is influencing um the behavior
choices
and and i'll talk more later about
places that that might not be a good
assumption
and then the fourth one which i think is
again very common
um and there's been new work on this
that i'll talk about more at the end
is an overlap assumption and this is
also very important
and the sort of basic assumption this
makes is let's say that you have
some pi e so some evaluation policy
that you're curious about and then
there's some pi b
which is use your called behavior policy
this was used to gather the data um
and this could be so pi i'll try to
generally use pi
or pi e and you could imagine that
under your pi be that induces some
distribution over your states and
actions this could be
stationary or it could be per time step
and then you have an evaluation policy
that would also induce a distribution
over states and actions
and the key assumption of overlap is
that any
um state action tuple for which you
would have non-zero probability
under the policy you're curious about
has to also have non-zero probability
under behavior policy in some ways this
is very intuitive you know if you have
um never tried driving to the airport
and you've only ever taken the subway
um and then there's no prior data that
you would have to be able to estimate
how good it would be to
drive the car to the airport this is
sort of saying you're going to give this
a coverage assumption
um some of these assumptions are not
made explicitly in some papers but i
think that it's really helpful
to be explicit about them um without you
know too much unnecessary formality
because
i think that they're often critical to
the types of
results that we would hope to be able to
see even empirically
so those are common assumptions the last
thing this or the last important part of
this cube to me
is um you know what are we trying to do
you know how would we
how do we compare algorithms and um uh
what are the evaluation criteria
and ah so somebody asked what is mu mu
here is
um the distribution of states and
actions that we would expect to observe
either per time step
or in a stationary chain under the
behavior policy
mu e would be the ones we would expect
to see under
our policy we're curious about possibly
an optimal policy
so this question of um you know what is
our evaluation criteria or what is
um sort of the success metric we're
considering i think is really important
um and i think in general in rl we've
seen very different approaches in rl
depending on which aspects of these
people consider most important
so one thing that i'm not going to talk
too much about today but i think
is a you know a very important
consideration particularly if you do
have the option of getting more data if
you can kind of trade between
um if computation is kind of the same as
data collection which it can be in
simulators
um then computational efficiency can be
really important and a number of
um papers are really focused on that and
it's also can be very important in terms
of just allowing us to tackle the size
of the problems that we want to
so i don't want to diminish
computational efficiency um
but it's not i'm going to mostly not
focus on that today i'm going to mostly
assume that
because the data set is fixed and often
the cases we're thinking about are more
high stakes
that it is more important to be
statistically efficient
and to sort of leverage additional
computational resources
particularly for the case that we're
going to sort of pick a single policy
and then deploy it for a long time
so we can maybe afford to spend a lot of
computational effort to decide what new
way we're going to sort of roll out for
maybe a new medical treatment and i'm
happy to discuss
other people's opinions about you know
which choices they think are most
important in terms of the valuation
criteria
the second one is performance accuracy
the first way i've written this down is
essentially
empirical mean squared error
so what you can imagine in these cases
is that um
and i haven't sort of i'll put an eye
here too so imagine you have a bunch of
different data sets
um this is just like your empirical
benchmark domains for example
so maybe m1 is you know half cheetah
m2 is carpool etc so you have a series
of
benchmark domains
such as uh d4rl
which sergey levine and other colleagues
from i believe um berkeley as well as
google
put out and so you have these benchmark
domains you have data sets from each of
these
benchmark domains you have particular
policies that you're interested in
evaluating or learning and then what you
do is you evaluate your performance on
that set of benchmark domains
so that's what i mean by the first and
so this is sort of an empirical version
of
accuracy for your method the second is
consistency
so that we want to know that in the
limit as the data set goes to infinity
that our estimate of the value of a
policy is converging to the
true value of the policy and then the
third would be something like finite
sample guarantees
where we get bounds that are as a
function of the data set size
about how good our estimate is and and
there's related other things like sort
of confidence interval
and also regret guarantees so
the regret guarantees tend to talk about
how good is our resulting policy
compared to the best policy
and that comes in when we start to think
about optimization
so there's a question on discord saying
is it common to search only over the
space of stationary policies
oh um is it common to a
good question um is it common to search
only under the space of stationary
policies
pretty yeah i mean i don't think that um
there's sort of off-the-shelf methods
for doing
um i don't think the fields converge but
i think most of the time people focus on
stationary policies
and it depends on the setting if you're
in sort of episodic settings you may
want to think about
you know coordinate the incorporating
the time step
so i sort of summarize um you know the
different two tasks off policy
evaluation of policy optimization some
of the important assumptions that people
either make or don't make
um and some of the forms of evaluation
criteria that people use
um i think i had a question here about
what row is thank you i didn't define
that
rho is generally the starting state
distribution
so we'll assume that we start from a
start state distribution
and we'll um ah another question which
is you know how would we compute
uh what v is you don't know what the
true v is
um in uh in benchmark domains you know
what the true
value of the policy is because you can
do monte carlo rollouts and so that
provides a ground truth that you can use
for empirical analysis
for these other approaches then we have
to use theory to prove that we're
actually going to converge to the
optimal
optimal value or what the finite sample
bounds will be
uh the last question i didn't quite
understand about what it means for the
how quickly the policy is learning but
feel free to clarify that
this is all in the offline case um but
the finite sample
guarantees give us a sense of how
quickly the estimate is converging
to the true value and the regret bounds
that i'll talk briefly about later
give us also a sense of how good we are
doing as a function of the amount of
data we receive
great so this sort of gives us a sort of
a landscape i think for
thinking about how to um compare and
contrast different types of methods um
uh because as i said that this field is
really fast which is super exciting and
i think even
you know in the la i had the pleasure of
um emailing with several different
colleagues um over the last week or two
to ask people
you know some of their favorite recent
papers um and i think
even this summer there's been a large
number of additional work so
it's a super exciting time to be
thinking about this so let me start with
batch policy optimization or let me
actually start with on
policy evaluation so this is going to be
this question of
someone gives us a policy this is given
you know we want to know some particular
slight change and maybe the order in
which we're going to give vasopressors
versus something else
um and then we want to figure out how
good that is we want to get an estimate
of its performance and the performance
i've put here is just sort of an
average over all possible initial
starting states that we would expect to
get
this can be weighed to different
starting state distributions and you can
also do
conditional average treatment effects or
try to get these estimates for
individuals based on the initial
starting state
so what are the types of methods that
people use to try to do this
offline or batch of policy evaluation
well the first two
are probably extremely familiar because
they're the standard things we do for
online learning
online rl um which is model based and
model free and then the
third and fourth may or may not be as
familiar
so the first sort of simple thing you
can imagine doing is you have a
collection of data
you didn't get it you didn't get to
choose how to collect it um but you have
some data
and so you just take that data and you
learn models
so we're just going to these are all
our estimated models
and if you're in the estimated one if
you're in the tabular model
tabular setting which i'm going to
generally assume or not but if you're in
the tabular setting
then it's just counting you just average
you know your reward in each of the
state action pairs
you look at your multinomial over the
next states you count your average
and then you can do policy evaluation
analytically
um because it's just a very simple
straightforward
uh policy evaluation uh with a finite
set of states and actions
so that's one thing you can do um and
you can do much more complicated things
than that you could fit
deep neural networks to try to build
reward models and
um uh and dynamics models
um and all of this is gonna give us sort
of
different ways to get some model out
that then we can treat as if it's a
simulator of the world and once you have
a simulator of the world you can
you know do online rl on that you can do
planning
anything you want to try to evaluate how
good this particular policy is
so one is to sort of try to map it back
to as if we know what what the dynamics
model and the reward model is
um and i'll talk more about uh models
later right now
remember we're just in the case where
we're given a policy so that's
input and so we're just trying to
evaluate it um one thing i want to
highlight
is that how we fit the model even in
these cases
matters so the method i just proposed
here would
and most of these with have typically
focused on maximum likelihood estimation
of the models
but because of this sort of covariate
shift problem that we talked about
that may not be the best thing to do
because you can imagine that if your
previous policy spends a lot of time in
states and actions that you don't expect
to see as much under your target policy
or evaluation policy
then your sort of representational power
may be being spent to the detriment
of some parts of the state space which
you actually want to model a lot better
because you're going to visit those
and so um i just want to highlight that
we've observed that before and so we
in um some work led by my grad student
yao lu and i'm in collaboration with
omar gotzman and finale joshi velez
we were really curious about if we
change the loss function for building
models
um to focus on the fact that we're going
to have this sort of covariate shift and
we're going to have this different data
distribution
can we can we get better models that we
can then use to do better policy
evaluation
um and what you're seeing in this case
is for one of our healthcare examples
this is a simulator
you can see that the green is the ground
truth um
orange here is the data this is the sort
of simulated trajectories you would get
if the way you had fit your prior data
was by maximizing the likelihood of your
behavior data
and what you can see is that if you use
our alternative loss function here you
get the
the blue which almost overlaps with the
green not everywhere but mostly
and so you can see that the types of
models that you fit can be very
different
if what you're planning to do is to do a
policy evaluation of a different policy
and in general i think this question of
you know what representation should we
build and what model should we build if
we don't just care about predictive
accuracy
but we care about either predictive
accuracy of a different distribution of
data
or to make future decisions um and how
that's different than the
sort of standard uh losses we use for
predictive accuracy
i think that's a super interesting
question um that i think there's still a
lot to be done
okay so that's you know one of the first
things we could do we could do
model based approaches um another thing
we could do is model free
value function approximation this has
also been done for a long time
um this looks kind of like q learning
but now we're gonna we're not gonna be
doing a max over actions
so we would just um parametrize a q
function
with a set of parameters it could be a
deep neural network it could be linear
et cetera
um and good thank you for the question
um about um sequential ignorability
versus partial observability
um i will come back to that there's
certainly connections um one of the key
questions is whether using the process
is actually identifiable or not
um or if the or if the confounding may
be more complicated
but if i don't if i don't answer it
again let me know
so a model free value function
approximation um you know like q
learning et cetera
um it's up for a fixed policy there's
many different styles of approaches this
there's
decades of research on this very very
popular for the online case
also very useful for the offline case
um i want to highlight that there's been
some nice
there's been sort of a series of nice
papers to try to analyze this case
more for the optimization case than per
the evaluation
but um there's a reason to ish paper
from lee voloshan
and u where they do do just fitted q
evaluation
which we can just think of as being q
learning function approximation q
learning
with a fixed policy and
so you get a generalization error of
something like the following which is
after k
iterations of fitted q evaluation for
this many samples
then i may get that wrong it might be
trajectories but samples trajectories
then you have with high probability
um this difference so you have the sort
of the difference between your estimated
value of the policy versus the true
value of the policy
scales is the following okay so i just
want to
highlight an important few things about
this so what are these different
quantities because i think it's useful
to sort of be familiar with what are the
standard different quantities
on which these type of bounds rely so
gamma here is our normal discount factor
remember k here is the iterations what's
d
pi f pi f here is
essentially
how well can we do um a bellman backup
for a fixed policy and how well can we
represent that
in the um the function spaces we have
access to
and so this is this is interesting
because it's not just about
realizability it's not just about
whether or not your value function class
can be represented
in the function approximator you're
using it's about whether or not when you
do
a dynamic programming backup
you know for a particular policy whether
or not then
that resulting object from like that
graph that we saw before
whether that already is close to the
original space
um and i think this is actually a super
important point so i'm just going to see
if i can go back
to here so that means you know when you
go from here
up to here it might be that in fact you
didn't leave the space
and so that this gap here is very small
and what this sort of gap here is
telling us is like how big you know is
this sort of projection gap
when you go back down
so that's really important that will not
always be zero but in many of the
existing
approaches we assume it is zero or it's
quite small
why would we like this to be zero well
um
no this is not um
this is not going to decrease as a
function
of n so n here
is telling us how much data we have and
then the error we get here
um in terms of as a function of n
is appearing here so we're going to have
some error that is going to be getting
smaller and smaller we have more data so
our statistical error is going to be
going down so that's good but then we
have these additional terms
which are not decreasing with the amount
of data because they're sort of
fundamentally
about estimation error the fact that we
can't um when we do these backups where
we may be incurring a different
additional error because we have when we
we need to project back into the space
so either one needs to assume that those
errors are zero
in order to get things that would be
asymptotically consistent um
or you're going to have sort of these
constant errors that aren't going to go
away so i
just want to highlight that and you can
think of those arrows as just being
like function approximation errors the
other thing that i want to highlight and
i'll go more into this later
is this term okay
which is um inter this question of
overlap
is really important in terms of how much
how does the distribution of data
that we reach under our behavior policy
compared to the distribution of data we
get under our evaluation policy
and as they get further apart as you
might expect it's harder to evaluate
a new policy under your old policy you
can imagine i'll just
draw pictorially if the distributions
your real distributions probably are not
gaussians but if your distributions were
gaussian you had a lot of overlap
then you would expect you think of this
as mu b
this is mu e over your states and
actions
then we if we had a lot of overlap then
probably if you have a lot of data
you're going to have a lot of ways
to estimate um let me put this out here
you'd have sort of sufficient data to
estimate your your target distribution
but if there's if they're like this it's
going to be very hard
or if it's extremely little um
if it's very unlikely to get data that
overlaps a lot so we'll go into that
um again more later um it is not there's
a question whether or not we can think
of beta as being
like kale distance it isn't i'm not
going to go into what the particular
definition
of concentration coefficient they use
here because it's sort of another one
that i think is a slightly different
definition that we'll use for
when we talk about some of the policy
optimization criteria so i'm going to
hold off on that now but again just
ping me if it's not clear when we get to
the next one so this is just an example
of the
of a recent pretty strong i think the
previous work may be scaled as
epsilon to the fourth this is only
epsilon squared um so
a a pretty nice result in terms of a
fitted q evaluation
theoretical guarantee okay what is the
problem with these methods both the
model free
methods of the value function or the or
the models
the dynamics in the world yeah uh
there was a question in the chat is beta
some sort of chao distance
uh yeah i think i just answered that so
um
yeah um but i i think i said that it's
not
and and we're going to talk more about
that assumption um
of what that sort of overlap and
concentration coefficient means when we
get to the optimization
but definitely ask me again if it's not
clear
so what is the problem with these
methods um so both
the model free methods and the the model
based methods
um the problem is is that they often
have bias
so unless you assume that your value
function really lives in the function
approximation
class that you've chosen then then
you're going to have bias in your
resulting estimator
and often it requires actually not just
this sort of realizability assumption
but additional
assumptions though there's a really
interesting recent paper that just came
out
i think like a couple weeks ago which
argues maybe we just need realizability
but but in general um in general we
won't know whether or not like your
function class
actually captures um the value function
that you're trying to estimate like for
healthcare or something it's hard to
know if you're
two layer you know 16 node or much much
larger neural network
is really approximating the true value
function or not
so often there's bias on the plus side
they're low variance
so they're often super data efficient um
but they may just have asymptotic forms
of
function approximation error or bias
so another approach is important
sampling um and i think these are
most distributed priciness but it's a
really beautiful idea so i just want to
refresh us
so important sampling has this gorgeous
idea which says let's think about the
expected
value of variable r which we can think
of for our purposes as being the reward
under some distribution p well imagine
that we
um i want to think about what if we
could only maybe sample from a different
distribution
so what we can do here so p here is our
distribution we can multiply and divide
by q of x which is another distribution
and then we can approximate this with
samples so then if we imagine that x is
just sampled from q
then we get an unbiased excuse me
estimator of the expectation of r under
p
by using samples that were sampled from
q
and the way that this is unbiased is
that we reweight those samples by the
ratio
of the probability of those samples
under
the sampling distribution we care about
which is p divided by q
so i think this is a really beautiful
idea i was talking to one of my former
students from my class recently he said
this was his favorite idea from
our rrl class so this is a beautiful
idea noted only it does require
overlap um otherwise this will not be an
unbiased estimator so this is
requiring overlap
but it's this beautiful idea that we can
use this behavior data
under this sort of overlap assumption
and we can get this great unbiased
estimator
now this is just for sort of um i
haven't talked to you about sequential
data so how does this work for
reinforcement learning
so for reinforcement learning we can
think about sampling trajectories
from our policy in a state and
imagine that we have both our behavior
policy and our target policy
and so we can again do the same sort of
important sampling trick
and we can say well what if we um only
have trajectories from our behavior
policy
um then we can think about generating
tricks for our behavior policy and
re-weighting them by the probability
of seeing them under our target policy
versus our behavior policy now one
natural question here is that we don't
have access to the dynamics model um
so how do we compute this but the
beautiful thing is that then if we
extend this out to write down what is
the probability of a trajectory
well that's just the probability of the
dynamics and notice
i've written it markov form here but
this this can be the full history
it doesn't have to be the markup
assumption the important sampling
estimators here this is this does not
require
so this bias does not
require markov assumption
this is a very general form of estimator
um and the nice thing here is that
the dynamics of the world are the same
whether you're running the behavior
policy or the reward policy
just the way you're selecting actions is
different so this cancels and you don't
need to know the dynamics model
and so we get an estimator here and this
idea um to my knowledge was first um
introduced to the rl community um
by pre-cop satnan singh back 20 years
ago um
and it has been used this and variants
of this idea have been used for
online reinforcement learning as well as
offline and batch rl
our group and many others have been
thinking about how do you leverage these
type of estimators
i want to highlight that over the last
couple years there's been also a
different form
of important sampling estimator that has
been getting a lot of attention and has
some really nice work
and this is a stationary important
sampling estimator
um and if we go again let's think about
sort of what is the the value of a
policy
well we can think of one way of writing
that is for all of the states and
actions
um this you know i used mu for this
before
so apologies um
but we could write it down as d we could
write it down as mu as what is the
distribution of visiting those states
and actions under this policy
times what is the reward of that state
in action and that gives us the value of
that particular policy
so again imagine that we don't have
access to
mu pi of s a or d pi of s a
this is we can think of this as sort of
the stationary distribution
so you can extend this to per time step
um but let's think of it for right now
and sort of infinite horizon stationary
distribution that we would get by
running a single policy and getting a
mark off chain
so then what we can do in this case is
play the same important sampling trick
assuming coverage so we have to sort of
assume overlap
so we introduce it to introduce this and
then we can say well the value of a
policy
is just equal to if i can sample states
and
actions um so these here are going to be
sampled from pi b
from our data set and then i'm going to
re-weigh them
by what is sort of um kind of the
density what would be
the probability of me being in that
state in action under my
target evaluation policy divided by my
behavior policy and this is leveraging
the markov assumption
so this assumes the markov structure
and my knowledge this was first um sort
of introduces an idea in
at least in the rl community by um
halika menora in 2017
and then there's been a number of
interesting follow-ups i just put a
subset of them here
um empirically it can often be very very
helpful
um because often important sampling you
have this product
of ratios that can lead to extremely
high variance as i'll talk about in a
second
um but here we have to sort of estimate
this ratio of densities
which itself can be quite
computationally challenging but there's
been a number of works
also sort of trying to focus on that
problem for like empirically
and other properties for for large data
sets how can we get
um enlarged problems how can we get the
sort of ratio
so may i ask a question related to this
what you just said uh it seems to me
that
this is a form of wishful thinking here
it could be really really uh information
theoretically difficult to estimate this
ratios or these densities and or
distributions
and if we could do that then we could
maybe
uh do other things to estimate the
values of
uh of the policies so whenever i see
these papers i'm really surprised but
as you say they like try to
uh so some of the works are empirical
and they try to do these approximations
and it seems to work but
i do you know whether it should work
is there any reason to believe that this
should hurt
i think this is a great question and i
one of my students were debating whether
or not um
fundamentally i mean if you can actually
capture
d pi of s a at least if you know the
reward you know the value function
exactly
so being able to estimate these
stationary distributions and we helped
estimate their ratio
um i'm not aware maybe somebody else um
one of
the other um members or attendees um
no i don't know of any lower bounds or
sort of formal hardness results of how
hard it is to estimate either
the stationary distribution stationary
distribution ratio and and some of these
works also depend on
you know do we know pi b explicitly or
do we also have to estimate that from
data
just the form of density estimation all
right
uh the density it is what's the ratio of
density
right yeah yeah i'm not aware of any
like hardness results um i am one of my
students are curious about
whether it um it fundamentally is
is equally hard as sort of how much this
actually buys you though i think that
leveraging the markup structure
certainly is helpful um
empirically and i think that it will
help us with the model based case
the markov assumption used they're using
the fact here that you're going to have
sort of these stationary chains
well you're going to converge to the
market like some stationary distribution
for some magical reason not because of
the mark of assumption this would
be just the expression that you could
write
yes it's a good point i think in this
case a lot of
this line of work i think of as
the not all of this line of work
uses these ratios there's other work
i'll talk second about doubly robust
assessments there's other work that
takes a doubly robust estimation and
tries to leverage the stationary
distribution there too
and so to me i think of this as sort of
like important sampling estimators that
leverage a markov assumption but i agree
there might be other assumptions that
you could use as well
let me see if i can just go a little
further in this before we break for
this um so the nice thing is you know
these give us this unbiased policy
estimates assuming the assumptions hold
um i just want to highlight that those
unbiased policy estimates don't always
lead to good policy selection
um essentially because we have different
variances
so you know some of the different
methods may have
some of the different important sampling
estimators depending on how far your
policy is from your behavior policy
can have systematically higher variance
and so if you start to use
these unbiased estimators and take a max
over those
unsurprisingly then you can have
systematic bias
so we sort of have these two styles of
approaches we have these models which
are
of either the value function or the
dynamics and rewards which have low
variance but often have bias
and then we have important sampling
which under mild assumptions
is unbiased but they can have high
variance because it depends on these
ratios
and so i guess one thing i'll just say
and then we can talk more about it after
the break is that um a really natural
idea is to combine between these two
um so that we have sort of these
parametric or even non-parametric we
have these
estimators perhaps with high bias but
low variance and then we've
these other estimators that have high
variance and low bias
um and while there's been a lot of
empirical work i think that the doubly
robust framework is a really useful one
to think about for how that's kind of at
least one really nice way to combine
between these two
and this is these doubly robust
estimators have been very well known in
statistics these are things that i
learned about it um i don't know maybe
about five years ago i think they're
really beautiful
they were brought over to the machine
learning community to my knowledge by
sort of
miradutic and colleagues at msr um and
then nan jang and li hong li
first brought these ideas over to rl
again to my knowledge
um and the idea here is to say well
let's kind of combine between these
estimators
um so that we could have a value
function
estimator that in our case might be
computed using
a model estimator and doing planning or
it could be computed with model free
estimators
but um but essentially get a value
function of a policy you're curious
about
and then you have um this here is just
for the um the bandit setting but you
would have your reward received
um and then you'd have this model and
then you would include here
um the important sampling ratio
and what you can see here is if you then
take an expectation over your policy
and i think one thing that i should
mention here that's important is that
most of the time here we'll be thinking
about stochastic policies when we're
doing important sampling
so that means that this would have to be
stochastic and this is quite reasonable
if your behavior policy only ever takes
one action in one state
you're not going to be able to
interpolate what it would be like to
take other actions unless you make other
strong assumptions
but i think the nice thing here is you
can see if you take sort of an
expectation over
this quantity by the data collection you
have and i'll just rewrite this as pi b
to be consistent with my other notation
so if you take sort of a sum over
actions for pi b of a given s you can
see that you recover um the original
important sampling estimator and
um and so we have this estimator that is
unbiased
and has some additional nice properties
so um it has some really nice properties
in particular
i'll just highlight this one before we
pause um
it's consistent if either um let me see
if it'll work priority not right now
it's consistent if either the model is
consistent or you can estimate the
behavior policy consistently
one thing i haven't highlighted so far
today is the fact that
in many observational data sets you
don't explicitly have the behavior
policy
so we don't normally have for physicians
but you know what is the probability
they're going to assign me aspirin
versus tylenol
so often that just has to be that sort
of a latent um
to the data and so often for important
assembly estimators we're going to be
estimating
that in order to use important sampling
estimators and the estimator you have
there might also be wrong
and so one of the nice aspects about
doubly robust estimators is that they
show that these are
these type of resulting estimate of the
value of a policy
is consistent if either the model is
consistent so either if this
you know estimate the value function is
consistent or you can estimate the
behavior of policy consistently
and so it sort of gives us some nice
assurances that the resulting estimators
may be good
so i think i'll pause there and then i
will pick it up
for the second part of the talk at
two o'clock
i'm mute thanks
thanks for the private talk
it does sometimes feel like that when
one's talking to well this time you were
live otherwise one just thinks you'll
see
this do these
and we continue after the break
i need to grab the espresso
all right thanks everybody